Donna is in North Carolina hey Donna
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Davis
Dianna
oh I'm sorry Dianna I missed it I
apologize how can I help okay
I have over a hundred thousand in
student loans that Carly on poll but a
current interest cuz I'm in bankruptcy
and I'm trying to figure out how do i
factor that into my debt snowball well
if it's in the chapter 13 bankruptcy
everything that's in the chapter 13
bankruptcy should be the last item in
your debt snowball your bankruptcy in
other words would be how many debts do
you have that are not in the chapter 13
bankruptcy just a suit long the student
loans not in it
no okay the bankruptcy does not put it
on hold if it's not in the bankruptcy
was in the bankruptcy but I don't pay
towards it so it's still I don't get
caused and I can't access my information
online I can call an act for how much
the balance is and it seems like that
questions but it's really not nothing
for me to pay when at the sonic a set
amount that I'm saying is not doing
anything for the student loan and
student loans are not bankrupt able
meaning if you convert it from a 13 to 7
it doesn't go away so you're still going
to have this hundred thousand dollars in
debt how much debt do you have other
than that that's in the bankruptcy that
this left or could only have like less
than a year left okay how much is left
in the bankruptcy I'm 3,000 almost
nothing good you're going to come out
the back of this thing and that hundred
thousand is going to be staring at you
right I got you
okay and what other debts do you have
they're not in the bankruptcy um I do
have 401k loan and that's about 10 years
ago that I had chose the lowest amount
to pay and that comes out of my check I
do have some medical bills that I'm
paying
calm through one through a company that
consolidates and then the other ones are
just Samantha's been coming in and then
I do have some too low balance cards
that by next month I'll be able to pay
off and cut up okay so what is your
household income I bring home about
forty eight thousand and you're single
yes with the child
how old is your child sixteen
how much is your house payment um 715 is
my rent
how much is your car payment the car was
included into the bank so it'll be paid
off in the year yeah okay okay let me
tell you what I heard okay you can you
can push back and tell me I'm wrong
mm-hmm but I hear a pattern of you got
out of control with money mm-hmm and you
went into bankruptcy you conveyed out of
control with money so you couldn't pay
your medical bills you stayed out of
control with money so you took out a
loan on your 401k and you stayed out of
control of money so you used credit
cards all of these things happen after
you file bankruptcy almost five years
ago you know my bankruptcy only been
three years ago so the 401k is before
that but the thing is I was out of
control and I kicked myself in the butt
October last year and said that I am
getting in control in 2020 okay good
because here's the thing if you keep
reaching for these traps as your way out
you're never gonna get out you reached
for a 401k loan you reach for credit
cards you reached for bankruptcy and
none of them have gotten you out the
bankruptcy kept them off of you until
you until you get around to it but it
didn't get you out what gets you out is
living substantially unless the
you make with a written budget and so
how long have you been a single mom I
didn't see my mom since 2006 you been
fighting us awhile mm-hmm yeah why you
by yourself okay right okay all right so
what we have to do is we have to change
your overall habits with money pretty
drastically so that your income is going
to be way more than your outgo your rent
is not out of control you're getting
ready to have a paid off car the credit
cards are almost gone so you've got some
cleanup to do with the 401k loan and you
got some cleanup to do with the medical
bills and then we get to tear into the
knocking out this mammoth Mount Everest
of a student loan right right so I'd
call the student loan people when you
come out the back of the bankruptcy and
just say hardship hardship I can't pay
anything right now
because you can't and in the meantime
let's really tear into while you're in
this this last year let's tear into and
clearing up the the 401k loan and the
medical bills because if you've got no
payments when you come out the back
route of the bankruptcy and you're on a
tight budget and you're under control
and you can start throwing some money
towards this student loan in a very real
way you probably turn this around and
get that student loan and whacked out
you're going to be working extra when
your child finishes up and leaves home
you're probably going to 60 80 hours a
week for a little while to clean up this
mess what do you do for a living
I'm a billing clerk so in their set
hours so I don't get opportunities I've
been looking for little right now
looking for little things that I can do
that doesn't take too much away from my
son yeah that's good and then you can
expand that when he's 18 and gone or 20
and gone right
so yeah you got a billing clerk you got
a the ability to side hustle helping
small businesses with their bookkeeping
or something right mm-hmm
you could do that so or something along
those lines I don't care but you need
some more money coming in because we
need to throw me if we throw $2,000 a
month at the student loan that still
takes us
for years mm-hmm and you don't have
$2,000 a month right now right so you
would you probably we could probably
find $1,000 a month in this mess once
you get the other stuff off of you and
get on a tight budget you increase your
income by $1,000 a month that's your
2,000 but you got four hard years of
that and you can make this go away
because four years forty eight months of
two thousand is right out a hundred
mm-hmm we can get there I can show you
how to get there and I'll walk with you
okay okay but you cannot keep going back
to I'm out of control I lose hope I get
scared and so I plug I plug my finger in
the stupid socket why you got to stop it
because you've done it like four times
or five times in this story yeah you see
the minute you see the pattern that I'm
seeing yeah okay and I want to help you
change it I'm not picking on you because
I did dumber than you did that's how I
learned this stuff all right
now I needed to hear it so on it hey
we're on the same team we're on the same
team I'm here to help you you hold on
and I'm gonna sign you up for a
Financial Peace University I want you to
go through the class I'm gonna pay for
it and help you okay okay thank you all
right Donna you hold on we'll take good
care of you you call me back they got
questions and I'll pick on you again
cuz I love you thank you for calling